- one 50, one 50,
one 50 a day until payday.
Mm.
(upbeat music)
- Friday's payday for ya boy.
(energetic music)
- Okay, we have two pieces of bread.
- Hey, an almost empty
jar of peanut butter.
- And a cup of noodles.
- We can make this work.
- Mhm.
- Damn, why's this couch so clean?
- I guess we'll just have to wait it out.
- I knew I shouldn't have
bought that shirt last week.
I'd still have two more dollars right now.
- Where did you find a
shirt for two dollars?
- The homie.
- The homie?
What?
(buzz and beep)
(bird chirp)
- Hey.
- Mm, payday, payday,
payday, payday.
(playful music)
♫ News I got good news
♫ It is the best news in the world to me
♫ News I left the blues
♫ Far behind and what a day
♫ It's gonna be
- Oh, hold up, y'all.
We gotta pay rent.
Yeah.
My bad.
We gotta do it, though.
♫ News I got good news
♫ It is the best news in the world to me
♫ News I left the blues
♫ Far behind and